and then when I saw you there and I'm
not gay you know that right there was a
delay there was a large delay anybody
says you know please PLEASE right first
question my head yeah I'm not okay I
mean that I mean I but let me just say
this all right I I go so like in the
person you're so handsome
well thank you pariah and there was
something you know here when white dudes
you don't have this you have nothing to
do with this okay George
you're ugly fugly problem yeah but dude
when white dudes smile and they have the
little crows date their eyes twinkle
there are the good ones
yeah doesn't have it
when he smiled there's no crow because
he doesn't ever smile it's forced but he
he is so happy right over his years of
being him right that he is genuinely
happy so his eyes crinkle right and so
when he smile I got off [ __ ] man
I'm gonna have to [ __ ] do this
because of that dude right there you
know it was nothing like that cuz you're
a family man but my point one this is
that I love this family party
damn I missed out yeah but I was just
like this guy right here dude is one of
the good whites and you know what new
bands the good whites good whites that's
right so I said I was a band name they
showed me that little thing that you
guys are short well yeah promotional
video it was that's how the whole thing
started so yeah yeah so Diplo was good
doing this Mad Decent block party tour
and his management and asked Brandon
Dermer this young up-and-coming
brilliant music video director to come
up with a concept and Dermer his concept
was what if james Van Der Beek
Diplo but like a Dollar Shave Club type
vibe did you know did you know him at
the time I didn't know Dermer at all
Wow I just obvious because you kind of
the same kind of same kind of thing came
to me out of the blue but no [ __ ]
money I mean like nothing cuz they were
there it was just like his man it was
like writing the check to go make the
commercial for the thing right um but I
had heard Diplo on the radio like a
couple years earlier talking about how
he made music and it something about
fusing like Latin beats but like
reggaeton like also it's like wow this
guy's kind of a genius
yeah so just flagged him as like
somebody to watch so when it came in and
it was Diplo is like well I mean [ __ ]
it's I mean I you know I usually get
paid for something like that but I'll be
associated with the bullock is amazing
yeah so um I met with Brandon loved him
and I said you know are you open to like
notes on the script and he goes well
I'll just send to the FDX file like the
final draft file Wow which is doesn't
really ever happen like yeah director
who's written something is like oh yeah
you can just just rewrite it which I did
and santim he's like yeah it's great so
we went out and shot it had a really
great time and then and then my son came
to us and said we think this is a series
Wow and that's when I was like it's not
a series not a series like I like I'm
the only reason I took the call with
Dermer was cuz he was so nice I had such
a good experience with them like Brandon
you know I know you're excited cuz you
know you'd get the directors series but
I just didn't see and then that night I
just thought I'll give it a chance I
went to my pool house I put on some
Diplo my headphones well like that's why
and I was like wait a minute this you
have a pool house totally a serious
stopstopstop
you a [ __ ] pool house I know there's
there's no bathroom so basically let me
say something you have a pool I have a
pool okay you have a swimming pool yes
and the swimming pool there's a house
there's a there's a shark that's
separate right separate and you can and
you can just relax in there as long as
there's no tiny little Vanderbeek
banging on the door i'm alois why you're
back there you'll all the tiny
Vanderbeek spur sleep Wow
yeah and so that was like this is this
yeah and I might have said this a lot
but it's like this is EDM Jesus sucks it
life yeah and I thought this would be a
really cool way to examine like the
truth about life especially because it's
for Vice it's for Vice land their whole
thing is kind of truth and by the way
[ __ ] you like I think that they're
actually slogan yeah yeah and so I
thought this would be a really cool way
to like find the truth through the eyes
of a clown yeah cuz Diplo is really he's
very like childlike and there's a kind
of cool like charm to him and he's a DJ
the end of the day so you can't take
yourself too seriously yeah so I was
like let's you know do this right at
find the truth and then just layer
stupidity on top of it right so that was
the that was my new I had never heard of
Diplo
oh really ever number one when I when I
got the kaga what the [ __ ] is a Diplo
number two this is a funny one time we
were shooting and I did this you go I
met chick come over here you put me in a
room yeah and you put on like a Diplo
song uh-huh check this he made this for
us you know whatever yeah and I didn't
know what the [ __ ] it was because you
just don't listen I just don't listen to
that kind of music
it's just saying yeah yeah so I wish I
had that same kind of enthusiasm that
you did right I'm sorry that I don't
bring that to the table my friends all
good as you bring you back all right
yeah now I know who he is yeah I Oh Co
is and all that so you're in there and
then you you're in the pool house and
then with the next day you call and go
let's do it yeah I call and I was like I
know how to do this I think I know how
to do this and I pitched it out and I
was like if you let me write it and run
it I'll star in it we can go like page
it device Wow and so I totally leveraged
like my my involvement to to get my
first show running gig
[Music]